I am to be married Emperor
Peter of Russia
yep
Russia Emperor Peter I present this
branch of spruce it is an evergreen and
I hope it will be a symbol of our
feelings for each other that we will be
constant in caring all our
lives she gave me a twig she's not
another bread is she husband
wife stop that move
over come
Empress they burned out my school you
must seek Justice wreak havoc upon them
you did not say this school was for
girls women here cannot read and they
shall not women are for seeding not
reading
oh dear someone's
cross good shot
huh we've got problems haven't we you
are the only person who has not loved
me if you had shown me an ounce of
kindness I was ready with a heart full
of
love you look really pretty my heart is
breaking
what happened to that happy little girl
who gave me a twig she
died don't look at me like that you're a
disappointment to me too now you my
dearest nephew I was noticing the
unhappy nature of your bride she does
not love me everyone else does so the
fault lies with her your mother once
confided in me that she saw something
within you that made her heart curdle oh
I wonder whether Catherine has seen the
same thing and it is stopping her from
loving
you I think I was angry because no one
has ever not liked me or at least
they're pretending
to tou what
T do you mean touche what is it not
touch no touche see that's great how
smart you are point is it's a new day a
time to put things behind us we are
agreed
oh that one is raner as is your whole
idea I come to you to help you see
reason your obvious unhappiness
endangers you what way he will kill
you you know as a young boy Peter would
run to his mother holding a loft a
picture he' drawn or a boat fashioned
from leaves his eyes and words begging
for approbation
for love she would level a gaze at him
and hold him in it and he would fall
silent and go so still and then tears
would run from his eyes and his whole
body would begin shaking uncontrollably
so I'm asking for some forgiveness some
empathy from one I can tell is filled
with
both good evening
husband I apologize if I have been of
sour face lately Let's us dance
[Music]
I have brought you a gift I promised you
a
lover a lover it is thoughtful of me I
agree this is Leo my spies tell me you
have kept Leo as your lover I did don't
fall in love with him or I'll bust his
head open with a bat you would like to
be loved I am
loved someone tried to kill you
t
a she was cruel to you she worried I
would not be
enough you can
be it is as simple as deciding to be
thinking about your
father the end of your first wall and
he's not here to see
it
yes how do you
know you're my
husband good
luck I need to tell you something
strange has happened Catherine you ever
noticed Catherine's eyes her hair it is
very gold like the sun and she thinks
like me so often today she says it and I
am like exactly and she cares more
whether or not I die than I do it is you
love
her hilarious GLE I have odd feeling
for you for me it is strange
but I may love
you I want to touch your hair
[Music]
and good night what have you done with
him me nothing he's gone to Venice I
said he should face you but he could not
cow have you killed him no I promise you
he is alive and well he does not love
you that is all but we just need some
clear air together and you will love me
and forget him probably in a
week let us talk when you calm down you
will one day look at this it's a funny
story to tell our
children he does not love you and it
hurts but you do not love him you love
me never you're mad man
oh my father used to say when a woman
wants to kill you you're in
business oh my
God you're the beaver's nose what you're
coming for
[Music]
Peter
she's also
[Music]
pregnant I thought we would call him
Paul I will cut your throat aim for the
belly you once told me that works a
treat you think a child will stop
me your child a
son the preservation of your line your
blood Peter the Great's grandson and no
doubt a cutie
I loved you you love me and you
love Paul you won't kill us why don't
you love me by the way I do in a
way but I love Russia more you're not
even Russian no I
can't give it
up I do not want any more Bloodshed in
this
abdicate
God send word to cut Leo veron's head
from his body and bring it to us on a
tray no so how have you been how have I
been yes at war with you that's how I've
been well hasn't it been great I've
loved it they so sweet sometimes I could
just kiss you on the
nose oh sorry did that hurt so many
great reasons for you to give up for
instance we can not a strong argument I
bet you've missed my tongue I did dream
knew about cutting it out so perhaps my
patience is wearing
thin love you bye
[Music]
Paul are you kidding that could have
been
me you all right
yes he will abdicate but he wants one
thing yes 20 minutes a day with Paul and
you how will you spend your days while
I'm making Russia better while you
improve Russia I shall improve myself
you're my wife Paul is my child I will
protect that which I love no matter
what do not be a you have kicked
me and made your point and I have taken
it graciously the Tiff between lovers we
are not lovers we will never be lovers
you wish to dance if it pleases you and
sort of even if it
doesn't we would need music I have music
in my hand that does not
[Music]
help
you do not love me you think you do but
you do not I know my heart I love you
stop saying it you love me and I love
you that is the truth I don't love you I
will never love you in the way you
[Music]
hope this all got horribly
wrong
hypothetical a woman who has loathed you
tried to kill you overthrown you and
imprisoned
you walks into a
room and tells you she loves
you what do you
[Music]
do first try and start breathing again
and
[Music]
then I have changed him and Peter is my
great
love is his wife and killed your
[Music]
mother
May
Catherine I'm
honestly
just so
sorry
[Music]
and this is Rosemary
look at
Catherine like an excitable little moth
to a handsome
flame you aim to RI
the I like it I'm powerless and my love
for you you tried to kill me and I did
nothing when she fell did my mother look
happy don't scratch the wound make me
forget
[Music]
I the American ambassador on my desk
which has left me feeling kind of breezy
funny I did it for us and because I felt
like
it you are my great love would you
mine when when I killed you or thought I
had it did not take my pain away but you
loved me more than you hated
me I do not want his first word to be
why not he has focused on what will be a
joy in his life he's like you huzzah and
you love me I will remind
you not
today
not happening don't you dare the
ordination is cancelled what there are
lines that cannot be crossed my son's
Destiny is one of them do not even
threaten
it chosen by
God and loved by
Daddy I've thought on it I will allow
the Stag ritual huzzah but not the
ordination you ask too much of me of
Paul
I ask you to choose
us pull the
surf
how dare you is he ordained then is
a I know what we should do we should
just take the Army march on Sweden take
it back I don't want to invade Sweden or
guess what I would have we don't do many
things
together sometimes words are clearly not
enough you wish to fight me if I need
to I have to do this my father appears
to me as in you actually see him I do he
wants more of me him oh I want more of
me me as I am is not enough that is mad
you are the most enough I have ever met
you hear old voices Hugo Peter the Great
calling you back to a place you have
left but hear my
voice I see your son's
eyes way they brighten when they're on
you and yours on
him and
us we have Rewritten each other in the
best most infuriating
way that is
enough close to
enough you do this and you can't come
back you're angry I mean it
Catherine I mean it you don't I
do you kill me every day you bend me in
my rain enough enough there are many
versions of you and you know I'm the
only one who sees them
all yes and you know I love them all
even when I find them baffling and
idiotic yes you do I just ask the same
of
you you think I am destroying us and I
know I am saving us I love you my whole
heart and all my body and whatever
ineffable Spirit animates me
everything I remember after the tortured
dinner and he told you he loved you for
the first time and he came to my room
shaking because he'd never felt anything
like it and for days afterwards he would
make me taste
things everything
seemed sharper to him like the forest
throbbed and oysters were a wave of sea
I he said you would obliterated the old
world he knew and replaced it with this
shimmering one
[Music]